jump higher and hit harder than any of
your enemies let's suit up head to toe
hydraulics highly pressurized pneumatics
hairy Hui is more like a vacation for me
because it's the first time in my career
I get to play a British character which
is what I am and so it's full circle and
that made it a lot lighter because
obviously the move is a bit more
slapstick I'll play a guy that kind of
runs and recruits to the rookies and
trains and so it's more fun but you know
with a serious tone but it was a you
know you can't be that serious when
you've got this huge Gatling gun that
you strap to a helicopter and the rubber
suits at Mohawk I mean you can't take
yourself too seriously you just have fun
with it I'd work with Steven summers
before I did The Mummy Returns so I was
very familiar with his his methods and
in part of those methods either he
requires all the actors to go for a boot
camp both in weaponry battle fighting
skills and just straight-out training
because it's a rig you know people don't
realize that these movies look great and
very sexy and flash but quite a rigorous
schedule and I mean and when you've got
a cast of maybe 10 people you're
shooting in repetition because you've
got to get everybody's lines so you may
do a stunt whether you jump in an 8-foot
war you have to do it 10 times just so
it's covered so you got to be fit
physically fit the video game is spawn
of obviously off of the comic on the
movie and yesterday I got the
opportunity to play for the first sign
you know I spent a lot of time
devised my character in it and man is
wicked but what's different about the
game as opposed to other games is like
most of them even give you the backstory
to the movie all they actually during
the movie like it's a continuum this
game actually picks up from where the
movie left off so you can actually play
it real time and it's wicked